In terms of Samsung Cambridge and Samsung Mobile,...
...what we're trying to do over the past few years...
...is to build a culture which holds people together.
That blend of startup versus big corporate...
...trying to take the best from both worlds has really been our aim.
This is ground zero.
This is really where it is happening.
It's an absolute privilege to work here.
This is where the cleverest minds in the country come.
I think there can be a misconception of the big Samsung brand...
...that we're very corporate and everyone has to wear suits to work.
We're not like that in any way, shape or form.
It is the definition of a Cambridge startup...
...and that's what we've tried to put into our office refurb as well.
Samsung supports us with the environment by treating us not as a number.
It makes your working life a lot easier.
I've worked in many companies in my life, but the philosophy is totally different.
This is family orientated.
It's a work-life balance and I appreciate that.